bonjour denis g houle bonjour
grave oui pardon merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france vous
avez suivi les annonces de jean castex
hier qu'en avez-vous pensé
mais j'en ai pensé que encore une fois
bien sûr il faut lutter contre le virus
bien sûr il faut promouvoir la
vaccination mais ça a été encore une
fois les annonces ont été faites sans
aucune consultation on a découvert en
même temps que tout le monde que que les
jauges allait être réduite que les
concerts de boala être interdit déjà où
on pense que c'est encore une fois une
vision très dur pour le spectacle
puisque on s'est limité les la
propagation du virus dans ce genre
d'événement et puis c'est encore une
fois une mesure extrêmement dur pour
ceux qui travaillent dans le spectacle
puisque les musiciens des techniciens
des artistes en général vont se
retrouver à nouveau sans travail puisque
on vit ça depuis deux ans et eu des
mesures insuffisantes ont été prises et
hélas c'est à nouveau du chômage et en
plus ça correspond au 1er janvier avec
la fin des prolongations des droits pour
un stand de deux personnes dans ce
spectacle donc c'est totalement
insuffisant les ministres s'étaient
engagés à revenir vers nous il ya une
dégradation la situation alors on les a
pas revus on leur demande de toute
urgence de réunir les représentants de
la profession pour savoir ce qu'on fait
et si ce sont les bonnes solutions le
problème c'est lol la jauge à 2000
personnes en intérieur j'imagine pour
les grandes salles de spectacle et les
programmations qui sont déjà fait
pour les plus grandes salles et pour les
concerts debout puisque c'est sans
aucune jose tous les concerts debout
même 200 personnes ou 200 personnes sont
annulés donc c'est énormément de deux
concerts dans les musiques actuelles
notamment pour les plus jeunes qui
aurait peut-être besoin de temps en
temps ou uniquement ne pas être confiné
mais c'est tous les concerts et il est
plus de 2000 évidemment c'est toutes les
tournées qui sont menacés tous les gros
spectacles mais encore une fois tous les
concerts debout et on avait déjà des
annulations tout ce pion au mois de
décembre les annulations pour les les
concerts qui sont liées aux festivités
dans l'est dans les communes avec à
utiliser territoriales les fêtes de fin
d'année où les sept des huit entreprises
ont déjà été annulée en décembre janvier
donc on vit à nouveau une situation
c'est un cauchemar qui se répètent com
de com avant les deux premiers
confinement ou
où on va vers des interdictions de plus
en plus grande et des mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont largement
insuffisantes qu'est ce que vous avez
fait des mesures d'accompagnement
insuffisante que qu'est-ce que vous
prenez ou de votre côté et ben nous on
prône que corot mettre sur le tapis la
question de compenser des revenus pour
ceux pour lequel c'est annulé c'est ce
qui a été fait pour dans certains
secteurs mais pour les intermittents du
spectacle ce n'est pas le cas là on nous
annonce au 1er janvier que c'est fini la
prolongation des droits alors que l'as
tu es comme si tu étais revenu de normal
en 2021 alors que c'est pas du tout
revenu normal ans comme on le voit même
avant les filets 5e vague et c'est à
nouveau le cas donc il faut il faut une
une des mesures pour compenser les
salaires qu'ils ont contre qui sont
annulés et il faut des mesures pour
prolonger les droits sociaux de tous
ceux qui travaillent en spectacle sans
oublier les autres essais les auteurs
qui sont même pas concerné par
l'assurance parce que le fait de ne pas
pouvoir faire de spectacle ou de concert
debout
induit que finalement il vaut mieux
annuler totalement les concerts
ne pas faire de concert debout fait que
des concerts n'auront pas lieu puisque
les salles qui ne vont pas se doter de
concerts assis et qui ont préféré
annuler donc toute les adulations de
fête pour tous les concerts debout ça va
être des annulations et on va pas équipé
d'un seul coup toutes les salles en
salles de concerts debout il ya des
tourneurs qui préfèrent annuler et puis
de toute façon les événements plus de
2000 personnes s'étaient travailler dans
le monde et ça c'est complètement à
bulles est interdite ça représente quoi
en manque à gagner concrètement le
manque à gagner je ne sais pas mais moi
je représente des salariés qui vont
perdre et je peux vous dire que l'on à
des musiciens qui ont ce qu'ils ont
perdu
les les questions de l'écran perdu tous
leurs concerts tous leurs tournois dates
de concerts du mois de décembre dix
dates des concerts au mois de janvier et
je ne laisserai l'ailé les patrons du
secteur 10 ans quels sont les pertes de
chiffre d'affaires mais moi ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'en perte de
volume de travail pour des pour pour des
personnes pour des intermittents du
spectacle par exemple c'est ses 15000
personnes qui vont se retrouver sans
rien il va falloir rembourser
évidemment ceux qui ont pris leur place
je vous poserai une dernière question
sur le fait que les meetings politiques
sont toujours autorisés
moi je suis pas contre que les meetings
politiques soient internes sont
autorisés mais c'est sûr qu'il ya deux
poids deux mesures on dire on dirait
qu'on peut attraper le le colis dans une
salle de spectacle dans une salle de
multiples de palpatine politique pense
qu'il ya d'autres façons de faire qui
serait justement de de mieux promouvoir
le vaccin est de faire en sorte que les
activités et lieux merci beaucoup d'amis
gravaud et d'avoir répondu en direct à
nos questions sur rt france